the travel industry was first to suffer
when the global pandemic hit america's
shores in march 2020
but one american company was more
exposed than any other
hertz the iconic car rental company had
a debt pile of over 20 billion dollars
and its debt was unusually unstable
to borrow money it used its fleet of
cars and trucks as collateral
however when travel and commerce
collapsed in the spring of 2020 under
stay-at-home orders used car prices
plummeted
lenders immediately demanded that hertz
pay hundreds of millions of dollars to
make up for falling auto prices
when the company decided it could not
find the cash
filed for bankruptcy protection in late
may
the hertz bankruptcy however would be
like no other
retail traders using the robin hood
smartphone app sent hertz stock price
storing something that almost never
happened for companies in chapter 11.
wall street experts dismissed the
phenomena as bored kids playing on their
devices who had no idea how high finance
worked
but it was the masters of the universe
who were taught a lesson by the spring
of 2021
leisure and travel were snapping back
quickly as the coronavirus vaccine was
being rolled out around the world
a bidding war had erupted between two
private equity firms each of whom were
going to have to pay a hefty ransom to
hurt shareholders who had been left for
dead just months earlier
the showdown culminated in a miami law
office overlooking the atlantic ocean
where the two groups took part in an
all-night auction in may
the winning bidders led by nighthead
capital and certairis agreed to pay
existing first shareholders 1 billion
valuing the whole of herds at 7 billion
well ahead of its valuation at the time
of bankruptcy a year prior
hertz has gone on to thrive since it
emerged from court protection even
inking a deal with tesla to buy 100 000
electric cars
hertz is now the symbol of the wild ride
financial markets went on during the
unpredictable and unprecedented coveted
pandemic when even the most troubled
companies found a shot at redemption
[Music]
you